un año como presidente de eeuu y un
panorama agridulce para joe biden llegó
al cargo con el mandato de unir al país
frenar los embates de la pandemia y
llenar un vacío de liderazgo tras la era
trump
éxitos los hubo consiguió aprobar un
paquete de alivio del cob y 19 de 19
billones de dólares en marzo impulsando
la vacunación y el testeo masivo también
logró aprobar un ambicioso plan de
infraestructura por un billón de dólares
para renovar las maltrechas carreteras
puentes y tuberías del país ya ha
conseguido bajar el desempleo de cerca
del 9% al 39 por ciento pero ante el
virus tal vez joe biden canto victoria
antes de tiempo aseguró que para el 4 de
julio día nacional el país había logrado
la independencia ante el cob y 19 pero
semanas más tarde llegó delta y más
recientemente omicron llevó al nuevo
récord de contagio
la fatiga pandémica de los
estadounidenses llegó al límite
una cadena de suministros golpeada dejó
algunas estanterías vacías y la
inflación alcanzó su nivel más alto en
casi 40 años la mirada también estuvo
puesta en la crisis fronteriza con
méxico donde los cruces ilegales también
batieron récord ya nivel internacional
la retirada de tropas de afganistán en
agosto daban fin a la más larga guerra
del país pero dejaba gravemente dañada
la imagen
365 días dejan a biden con una
aprobación en bajada pasando del 56 por
ciento al 42 por ciento de cara a unas
elecciones de medio término en las que
los votantes podrían arrebatarle el
estrecho control de las cámaras a los
demócratas by de aena hecho de la
aprobación de su proyecto de gasto
social y de la defensa del derecho al
voto sus nuevos caballos de batalla un
año de retos pero también de grandes
progresos así lo definió baiden en su
más reciente rueda de prensa un
presidente en problemas pero que ha
recordado que su trabajo no ha terminado